[Musik]
live aus köln der presseclub mit jörg
schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass sie dabei
sind wir hatten uns über jahrzehnte
daran gewöhnt dass zinsen und preise im
gleichschritt vorangehen das hat sich
schon mit der euro krise geändert zinsen
auf sparguthaben gibt es seit jahren
nicht mehr aber das war so lange zu
ertragen wie sich die preise praktisch
nicht bewegt haben und jetzt gibt es
aber einen regelrechten sprung eine
explosion das niveau der inflation hat
rund 5 prozent erreicht es springt uns
an den tankstellen ins auge die gas- und
stromversorger schicken uns kuverts mit
heftigen nachzahlungen und
preiserhöhungen und im super gau oder
elektromarkt kann man sich bei manchen
preisen nur noch die augen reiben das
bedeutet für viele dass das mühsam
ersparte weniger wert wird das heißt für
haushalte mit geringem einkommen dass
man in bedrängnis geraten kann wenn die
nachzahlungen kommen in berlin dort über
hilfen und steuersenkungen diskutiert
und die institutionen die eigentlich für
preisstabilität verantwortlich ist die
europäische zentralbank hat diese woche
den leitzins ungerührt bei 0 prozent
gelassen das ist unser thema im
presseclub preise steigen guthaben
schnellsten wie bedroht ist unser
wohlstand und ich freue mich auf diese
gäste ulrike herrmann ist wieder bei uns
wirtschaftskorrespondent in der
tageszeitung taz herzlich willkommen
ebenso lisa nienhaus sie leitet bei der
wochenzeitung die zeit das frankfurter
büro herzlich willkommen frau nienhaus
ich freue mich auf den ökonomen und
publizisten daniel stelter der unter
anderem regelmäßig verhandelt laut
manager magazin und andere organe
schreibt und andreas tyrock ist bei uns
aus dem herzen des ruhrgebiets
chefredakteur der westdeutschen
allgemeinen zeitung aus essen und bevor
wir hattrick mit der wirklichkeit
anfangen schauen wir einmal auf die
zahlen ich hab schon erwähnt das ist die
preissteigerungsrate die entwicklung der
letzten zwölf monate im dezember wurde
sogar die 5 geschrammt und überschritten
im januar ist es wieder knapp darunter
aber die prognose der statistiker für
dieses jahr liegt irgendwo zwischen drei
und vier prozent hat was bedeutet das im
alltag das bedeutet im alltag für viele
menschen dass sie wie sie es gerade an
moderiert haben sich wirklich gedanken
machen müssen wie sie über die runden
kommen es betrifft natürlich nicht alle
gehaltsgruppen aber es betrifft sehr
viele soziale hilfe
sozialleistungsempfänger betrifft aber
auch menschen die im niedriglohnsektor
arbeiten es betrifft rentnerinnen und
rentner deren rente nicht allzu üppig
ausfällt die sonst so auf naht
über die runden kommen und die plötzlich
merken dass ihre stromkosten die
energiekosten die benzinkosten derart
massiv steigen dass sie einfach nicht
mehr über die runden kommen über die ezb
anlagen wie viel zinsen kriege ich bei
geldanlagen machen die sich keine
gedanken weil sie legen nichts an wovon
und wofür aber es gibt sehr sehr viele
menschen die auch in den mittelstand
reihen besorgt sind trainieren aus wie
dramatisch schätzen sie die entwicklung
an also zunächst mal ist es die hertha
schon gesagt ist er hat besonders
dramatisch für die ärmeren in der
bevölkerung wenn man wenn die inflation
länger anhält wird sich das zehn- bis in
die komplette mittelschicht weil dann
passiert folgendes auch die leute die
sich jetzt ein bisschen höhere preise
leisten können haben ja irgendwo was
angelegt leider die mittelschicht häufig
in geld also in geldvermögen einfach
tagesgeld oder festgeld oder einfach auf
dem konto liegen und dieses geld
schmilzt in seinem wert weg das passiert
wenn die inflation länger bleibt und
damit betrifft sie irgendwann nachdem
sie jetzt anfangs vor allen dingen er
die geringverdiener betrifft später alle
ist sie gekommen um zu bleiben die
inflation naja man muss ja jetzt mal
gucken was die inflation treibt das sind
eigentlich im wesentlichen zwei dinge
das eine sind die energiekosten nicht öl
und gas und teurer geworden und das
andere sind eben nahrungsmittel die
teurer geworden sind der rest ist nicht
teurer geworden das muss man jetzt auch
mal so deutlich sagen aber dann komme
ich nicht jeden tag den rest ja genau
jetzt ist natürlich das problem dass
keiner in deutschland und auch die ezb
niemand ist hier ölscheich nicht also
wir sind abhängig letztlich von den
preisen auf den weltmärkten für gas und
öl und da ist jetzt die frage wird wie
wird sich das entwickeln und da sagen
die prognosen aber die können falsch
nicht dass der ölpreis wieder runter
gehen wird also im augenblick nur so zur
orientierung ist dabei 92 dollar das
barrel ein barrel sind 159 liter und er
die prognose ist das runter geht in
diesem jahr auf 73 dollar und dann ist
es ja auf 65 dollar dann wir das thema
wieder weg aber kann natürlich anders
kommen wie ist ihre einschätzung
erstattung ja google auch andere
prognosen die ölpreise von jenseits 100
dollar und bis zu 200 dollar in den
nächsten jahren vorhersagen einfach der
sägerei prognosen ja genau das immer so
ich meine muss sich einst im hinterkopf
haben wir haben im letzten jahr so wenig
in die
exploration investiert wie seit dem
krieg nicht mehr zweiten weltkrieg nicht
mehr und wenn wir weiter steigenden
anfragen in dem was ich exploration die
förderung von neu erschließen neuer
quellen in brasilien und wenn wir eine
weltweit weiter steigende nachfrage
haben die haben wir auch trotz allem
klima umbau dann haben wir natürlich
auch durch wendigkeit mehr angebot zu
schaffen und wenn wir das nicht schaffen
haben wir höhere preise nur schön der
einführung haben dass wichtiges gesagt
sie haben gesagt wir haben schon zehn
jahre eigentlich wo die sparer nichts
bekommen haben und auf den kern bringen
sie haben angesprochen sind vor allem
die geld spare richtig wenn jemand heute
10.000 euro hat erspart hätte ihren
letzten zehn jahren normale zinsen
bekommen hätte heute 15.000 euro das
heißt der 45 und jetzt kommt die
inflation unter schmilzt noch mehr ab
und wenn das jetzt ein paar jahre
andauert hat er plötzlich nicht mehr
10.000 sondern auf 5000 und das ist ein
massives sozial das problem bei was wir
erlebt haben letzten zehn jahren ist
dass diejenigen die die möglichkeit
hatten ihr geld anders anzulegen die von
der politik profitiert haben immer noch
mal ganz uns als letztes beispiel denken
sie an mittelschicht vor 10 15 jahren
hat ein junge familie sich eine wohnung
kaufen könnt ihr konnte der traum war
realistisch realisierbar er ist heute
nicht mehr realisierbar warum war die
preise von immobilien sich massiv erhöht
haben warum war es geld nichts mehr
kostet und das ist das problem jetzt
treten die nächste phase 1 wo noch mal
diese spaltung vertieft wird und da ist
die ezb nicht alleine daran schuld aber
sie ist mit daran schuld
ich halte mal fest also wir können über
prognosen lange streiten ob es besser
oder schlimmer wird niemand an diesem
tisch das ist das stichwort ezb ist
jetzt mehrfach gefallen ist auch der
grund warum wir gerade heute sprechen
weil die europäische zentralbank von
nienhaus am donnerstag mit ihrem rad
dabei geblieben ist die zinsen bei null
prozent zu lassen ich sag mal gruß an
alle die uns in den sozialen netzwerken
über presseclub und tagesschau folgen
danke für die rückmeldung ich lese dass
diese entscheidung der ezb
viele beschäftigten eine frage die immer
wieder gestellt wird ist warum tut sie
nicht endlich was hat sie druck ist sie
unabhängig warum lässt sich die zinsen
bei null prozent bei all dem was sie
gesagt haben erscheint das erst mal
nicht sehr vernünftig also vielleicht
sollte man erst mal sagen dass ich finde
sie hätte längst was tun sollen ja also
das ist meine haltung und ich
verstehe aber auch oder ich höre von der
ezb wieso sie das nicht getan haben und
das ist genau der grund den frau
herrmann vorhin schon genannt hat sie
argumentieren sehr stark damit wir haben
jetzt sehr hohe energiepreise diese
energiepreise können wir mit unserer
geldpolitik gar nicht beeinflussen also
tun wir erst mal nichts und hoffen dass
sie wieder fallen das jetzt ein bisschen
polemisch gesagt ja
etwas weiter vorher vielleicht also im
vergangenen jahr war es noch ein anderes
argument da war es mehr so man hat
gedacht wenn man sagt die preise fallen
bald wieder dann fallen sie vielleicht
auch wieder hatte ich so das gefühl ist
also ein bisschen magisches denken sowie
steuern die erwartungen wenn wir sagen
bald fragen die preise wieder dann
passiert das auch wirklich hat nicht
geklappt jetzt ist das argument die
energie und ich finde also darüber kann
man lange streiten aber frau lagarde
sagt selber 50 der jetzigen
preissteigerungen ungefähr gehen auf die
energie zurück da sage ich mir kann sich
die ezb jedoch auch um die anderen 50
prozent kümmern oder christine lagarde
ist die präsidentin ist keine frau von
ja was nicht ob man das so sagen kann
man sagen es keine frau von klaren haupt
setzen also sie spricht und formuliert
schon sehr klar aber man braucht dann
eigentlich deutung seminare um zu
verstehen was gemeint ist wir können mal
kurz reinhören auszug aus ihrer aus
ihrem statement am donnerstag
die europäische deutschland sagt sie
erholt sich gerade weiter gehen davon
aus dass das wirtschaftswachstum im
ersten quartal noch gedämpft sein wird
wie sich die inflation entwickelt ist
unsicher wahrscheinlich wird sie länger
erhöht sein als bislang angenommen aber
dann im jahresverlauf abnehmen ja
wahrscheinlich vielleicht also ist die
ezb gibt es in die runde hat erstellter
freiheit ist sie teil des problems oder
teil der lösung die eps
teil des problems das prinzip hoffnung
kann man reiten aber auf dauer ist es
keine lösung erstellt hat gerade
angesprochen hat vielen jahren ist das
so gucken kurz zurück die ursache der
nullzinspolitik liegt in der finanzkrise
liegt in den problemen auch in den
südeuropäischen staaten und mittlerweile
hat sich das verselbstständigt das ist
sowieso eine süße droge die man den
staaten immer wieder gibt und die man
hält südeuropa stabil man lässt die
sparer bluten die bisher sich das seit
jahren auch gefallen lassen muss man
auch mal sagen der staat selbst
hochverschuldet profitiert auch von
niedrigen zinsen das heißt es zum common
sense also ein allgemeingültiges
vorgehen auch in der politik in der
wirtschaft auch vorangetrieben durch die
ezb und man sagt auch als ökonom
vielleicht mit erstellt das auch ähnlich
argumentieren bitte nicht zu hoch und
nicht anziehen lassen weil das natürlich
den aufschwung und die ökonomie belasten
kann dass die argumentation dazu noch
einen satz dieses süße gift oder die
süße droge mag erst mal seit vielen
jahren funktionieren aber irgendwann
muss und drogenentzug aufkommen also in
mir persönlich fehlt das signal zu sagen
auf dauer müssen wir wieder clean werden
um im bild zu bleiben und da würde ich
mir persönlich wünschen von der ezb mal
ein signal zu senden wie sind die usa
zum beispiel passiert das problem ist
die ezb ist hat sich selbst in der
sackgasse manövriert die us notenbank
auch interessieren wir haben seit
jahrzehnten eigentlich schon vor die ezb
es gab amerikaners gemacht auf jede
krise in den finanzmärkten in der
wirtschaft reagiert mit noch mehr
belegen geld mit noch mehr liquidität im
klartext ami notenbanken immer
spekulanten gerettet und belohnt die
leute mit schulden arbeiten das ergebnis
der ganzen sache ist dass wir heute
weltweit zu viel schulden hatten wir
noch nie in der geschichte aus sorge
dass überschuldung von staaten oder
fragen hat im juni warten auf sie wartet
muss ganz wichtig gesamtverschuldung
nicht mehr starten das heißt sie haben
ein signal gegeben verschuldung lohnt
sich und haben deshalb die schulden
immer höher getrieben das wäre jetzt die
zinsen steigen haben die schuldner alle
ein problem und wir kriegen eine richtig
schwere krise das zweite ist die
vermögenspreise ich habe zum beispiel
gebracht der der deutschen immobilien
wenn sich die zahlen anschauen den
letzten zehn jahren können sie über 50
prozent über die hälfte des kursanstiegs
an den us-börsen alleine erklären mit
der bilanzsumme der us notenbank wenn
jetzt also geld knapper wird haben wir
das problem die schulter bekommen
probleme und die vermögenspreise fallen
da sah man kann nicht eine mit einige
zuschauer richtig so soll die reichen
noch verlieren kann man auch
argumentieren das problem an der ganzen
sache ist diese vermögenspreise sind ja
nicht so alleine sondern daneben stehen
auch schulden die leute haben ein kredit
aufgenommen um die wohnung zu kaufen
denn als die vermögenspreise fallen
kommen wir schulden unter druck und dann
haben sie eine abwärtsspirale und dass
das problem das wir jetzt haben die ezb
und auch die usa diese kann nicht viel
machen wir sind eine sackgasse wenn sie
die zinsen erhöhen die krise probleme
ganze sache ist nur jetzt gibt es
fundamentale faktoren die dafür sprechen
dass eine inflation bekommen
klimaschutzpolitik ölpreise
demografische entwicklung und dann kann
die notenbank nicht mehr reagieren und
dann ist in der tat das risiko groß dass
die inflation dauergast wird unser zu
höheren raten verstanden habe ich
sackgasse teilen sodass die überhaupt
nicht also
jetzt mal einfach ganz einfach bei den
bei den sparern zu bleiben die ja schon
angesprochen wurden also angenommen die
sollen jetzt hier die zinsen erhöhen
dann hätte ich als sparer vielleicht
ganz bisschen zinsen irgendwie 0,5
prozent oder so aber dummerweise wäre
dann mein job weg jetzt quizfrage an
alle zuschauer
wäre der job weg weil wenn jetzt der
hersteller hat das eigentlich auch schon
gesagt das stimmt wenn wenn die zinsen
hoch gehen kann ja niemanden ihren
kredit aufnehmen weil das teuer wird das
lgl das problem ist aber
ohne kredite bricht die wirtschaft
zusammen man kann eigentlich sagen
wachstum gibt es überhaupt nur wenn
leute auch schulden machen so das heißt
der wenn die zinsen hoch gehen gibt es
eine wirtschaftskrise und das gibt dann
auch arbeitslose und dann hätte man den
effekt dass die leute vielleicht ein
paar bisschen zinsen bekommen aber
dummerweise jetzt auch ganz viele leute
die keinen job mehr haben und man muss
jetzt mal in aller deutlichkeit sagen
die leute leben von ihrem lohn nicht von
den zinsen dh das wäre der wahnsinn
jetzt die zinsen zu erhöhen und hier in
deutschland haben viele leute das gefühl
auch hier haben wir ja schon fast
vollbeschäftigung und irgendwie geht es
uns doch gut aber wenn man jetzt die
statistik anguckt dann stellt man fest
dass auch deutschland immer noch nicht
auf dem niveau ist von 2019 also vor der
krise
in wahrheit ist auch deutschland in
einer schlechten verfassung was übrigens
daran liegt hat hat es ja schon
angesprochen das südeuropa auch kränkelt
jetzt können wir aber in deutschland
nichts sagen achte sowas ärgerliches wir
füttern die durch weil wir sind eine
exportnation exportieren vor allem in
die eurozone das heißt wir leben davon
dass sie den anderen auch gut geht kurz
und gut es wäre wahnsinn die zinsen hoch
so sei der preis hat sich halt halt
einmal einmal sacken lassen also danke
sie haben sich auch bemüht finde ich das
verständlich zu erklären und trotzdem
geht es ja um sehr komplizierte
zusammenhänge ich nehme mal ihren satz
bei hermann die meisten menschen leben
von lohn und nicht von zinsen genau
leuchteten jahren also selbst wenn ich
gut gespart habe und kleines vermögen
habe wenn nichts rein kommt mein job
wegfällt habe ich ein problem so
die ezb ist in der sackgasse weil es
wichtiger ist jobs zu erhalten die
wirtschaft nicht ab sagten zu lassen als
die zinsen zu erhöhen sagen die beiden
am tisch also bleibt es ewig so wie es
ist also dass ich will dem zustimmen
dass die ezb sich in dieser kasse
begeben hat und dass es tatsächlich
schwierig ist und man sehr gut aufpassen
muss wie man beispielsweise zinsen
erhöht aber wenn man frau herrmann
zuhört hat man das gefühl die ezb könnte
niemals wieder die zinsen erhöhen und
das glaube ich nicht also ich meine man
kann nicht immer argumentieren jetzt
geht's nicht und jetzt geht's nicht und
herz geht es nicht uns selbst am anfang
wurde immer argumentiert die inflation
ist so niedrig dass ist ja auch
verständlich die aufgabe der ezb ist die
inflation jetzt stark die installation
dann geht es aber auch wieder nicht da
frage ich mich sozusagen frau herrmann
tatsächlich direkte frage an sich an sie
denn jemals wieder die zinsen erhöhen ja
wenn es vernünftiges wirtschaftswachstum
gibt kann man die zinsen erhöhen aber
wie gesagt das gibt es im augenblick
nicht und was man mit den zinsen
tatsächlich beeinflussen kann ist
sozusagen die
innenpolitische lage das heißt die höhe
der löhne wenn wir die situation hätten
dass in deutschland die löhne sehr sehr
stark steigen was dann natürlich die
fabriken überweisen auf die preise und
am ende steigt dann auch die inflation
dann müsste man die zinsen anheben der
punkt ist nur die löhne in deutschland
steigen nicht extra nachgeguckt okay da
noch eine zeitung damit dass alle wissen
2021 sind die tariflöhne um 1,7 prozent
gestiegen das ist fast nichts also da
muss bei uns nicht angst haben dass
plötzlich hier näher stellt inflation es
geht also ich möchte mich ein smartphone
ich finde ich würde als erster stelle
steht ich finde es nicht gut die
situation die ezb gar nicht
entschuldigen sie doch selber daran
gewirkt dass jeder situation ist nur ein
richtig ist schon von ihm bin ich - bei
ihnen die ezb wird die zinsen nicht
erhöhen können wenn sie keine
staatsschuldenkrise keine schuldenkrise
zu lassen möchte und deshalb wird sie
den fehler begehen wie auch die
notenbanken amerikaner in 60er jahren
die inflation laufen zu lassen und
übrigens heimlich hofft man auch darauf
über inflation die schulden zu entwerten
um eine antwort darauf wäre eigentlich
politisch hier in deutschland eine
forderung nach dem wir unser währung mit
anderen teilen die nur mit tiefen zinsen
und höhere inflation überhaupt im euro
zu halten sind dann lass uns doch mal
überlegen wie der politisch darauf
reagieren in deutschland indem wir eben
aufhören und selbst als politiker zu
eine schwarze null zu loben nichts
anderes als das ergebnis der tiefen
zinsen nämlich der enteignung der sparer
also da ist doch die antwort er statt zu
sagen oh die ezb war dass die ezb das
der sackgasse ist liegt auch daran dass
die deutsche regierung geweigert hat in
der vergangenheit die eurozonen krise
wirklich zu lösen macht jetzt einen
harten schnitt
weil wir jetzt über die akteurinnen ezb
gesprochen haben über das problem zinsen
über die spannungen im euroraum mit sehr
unterschiedlich starken ländern
tatsächlich sind die preise aber da
selbst wenn die ezb jetzt zaubern und an
der schraube drehen könnte hätten wir
trotzdem die nachzahlungen die die
briefkästen flattern
wir hätten die probleme mit dem
russischen gas harter schnitt deshalb
hat wir haben drei landtagswahlen in
diesem frühjahr die spd hat die
bundesregierung in der führung
übernommen und kommt wie jede neue
regierung für die ersten monate schon
die quittung mit sinkenden umfragewerten
jetzt sind für den sommer
einmalzahlungen heizkostenzuschüsse für
haushalte mit wohngeld und andere
geringverdienende versprochen worden ist
es jetzt aufgabe der bundesregierung
dafür zu sorgen dass die größten die
härtesten folgen abgemildert werden
definitiv die bundesregierung ist
zweifach in der pflicht die
bundesregierung ist in der pflicht den
menschen zu helfen die unter der
aktuellen situation die wir jetzt
mehrfach geschildert haben zu leiden da
kann man muss man diskutieren sind
politische entscheidung ob man schon
über steuererleichterungen kommt ob man
über die energie steuer kommt ob man
über einmalzahlungen geht der
heizkostenzuschuss betrifft menschen die
sozialleistungen empfangen
das heißt er betrifft leuten menschen
die nicht in einem geringverdiener im
bereich sind sondern schon drunter sind
hartz 4 empfänger zum beispiel oder
studieren auch in einem großen umfang
die bundesregierung muss aus meiner
sicht diese härten abfangen auch im
bereich im unteren mittelstand wir
sprechen dann ja immer von den unteren
einkommen die oberhalb der grenze
sozialleistungsempfänger sind die die
früchte und schon gesagt habe die
wirklich auch auf kante genäht sind und
die im grunde bei 100 200 oder bis zu
1000 euro mehr energiekosten mit benzin
mit heizkosten die wirklich dann in die
in schwierigkeiten kommen das ist einmal
die verantwortung der bundesregierung
die ohnehin im augenblick reingestolpert
unter einem spd geführten kanzler ist
eine sozialdemokratische klassisch
sozialdemokratische aufgabe
und auf der anderen seite auch
sicherlich eine parteipolitische
entscheidung in berlin mit blick auf die
von ihnen angesprochenen wahlen unter
anderem die sicherlich politisch
wichtigste mai nordrhein-westfalen
grundsätzlich also verschiedene
maßnahmen werden diskutiert zustimmung
ablehnung hat gesagt ja das ist ganz
klar eine politische aufgabe also ich
bin ja ich bin ausdrücklich dafür so das
was der tür abgefordert hat dass man die
unteren schichten entlastet aber ich bin
dafür dass man es gezielt tut also man
sollte jetzt nicht mit der gießkanne
durch ganz deutschland gehen und jeden
entlasten und dann sozusagen um es etwas
zuzuspitzen hat am ende auch der
villenbesitzer noch profitiert nicht
also deswegen sind solche maßnahmen wie
generell zu sagen wir senken die
mehrwertsteuer auf strom oder so ist
schlecht weil dann jeder profitiert gut
ist wenn man tatsächlich versucht aber
es bleiben ja auch alle also erst einmal
auch die große mehrheit die jetzt schon
den sozialstaat bezahlt leidet hat ja
aber trotzdem
der staat muss ja finanziert werden ist
ja nicht so dass jetzt irgendwie im
staatshaushalt noch milliarden rumliegen
die darauf warten dass man sie mal an
die bürger verteilt und in anderen und
deswegen also um das jetzt gezielt zu
machen sollte man vor allen dingen die
ärmeren schichten entlasten also ich
finde den heizkostenzuschuss wie frau
herrmann richtig allerdings muss man
sagen der betrifft ich hab das
nachgeguckt tatsächlich 1,5 prozent
aller haushalte und das ist wirklich
sehr sehr wenig denn es sind sehr wenige
personen und das sind leute die wirklich
wenig geld haben und da ist es auch
richtig und da gehört das auf jeden fall
auch hin was den rest der
preisentwicklung angeht da muss man auf
andererseits sei es zum teil auch die
politik gefragt also dass zum teil die
ezb gefragt meiner meinung nach und das
zum teil auch die politik gefragt weil
bei den hohen energiepreisen geht es ja
auch sehr und politik da sind wir dann
beim ganzen problemen mit russland und
der ukraine etc wo bekommen wir unsere
energie her wie abhängig machen wir uns
und wie schnell kann man dafür andere
möglichkeiten sorgen die dann vielleicht
die preise auch wieder ein bisschen
sinken lassen also die politik ist auf
zwei seiten gefordert einmal so zu sagen
kurzfristig für die ärmeren und dann
aber auch um die energie irgendwie für
uns wieder günstiger zu machen zumindest
mittelfristig erstellt wo ich mal kurz
die kurzfristige antwort ist okay aber
nicht völlig bei ihnen nicht damals
strukturell haben eine ganz andere
antwort weil es ist ja ein thema was
dauerhaft bleibt energie wird auf
absehbare zeit nicht sondern teurer
wollen wir bewusst das ist ja unsere
klimaschutzpolitik ist wird teurer wir
sind wie gesagt im euro mit anderen
zusammen die auf inflation setzen da
müssen wir uns mal überlegen als land
was eigentlich unsere strategie der
wohlstandssicherung und da muss ich noch
mal sagen sie sprechen haben wir haben
überwiegend geld sparen da stimmt
italiener beispielsweise haben vielmehr
immobilieneigentum was können wir tun um
der breiten masse bevölkerung zu helfen
mehr vermögen zu bilden und dann muss
man auch die frage aufwerfen ist es im
wirklichen euro sinnhaft als staat eine
schwarze null anzustreben weil ganz
ehrlich wäre wenn alle schulden macht
spaß das ist der geisterfahrer auf der
autobahn
ok ich gebe ihnen hätten sich gemeldet
aber ich gebe ihnen noch mit
wolfers hatte ich hier bei twitter warum
werden auf die steuern wie zum beispiel
die stromsteuer die ich bezahle noch mal
wieder umsatz steuern fällig diese
mehrfach besteuerung abzuschaffen wäre
da schon mal ein anfang das wäre ein
anfang mehr aber ein steuereffekte wo
wir mal der ökonom gefragt ist sind
lichteffekte die frau habe man eben auch
zurecht angesprochen hat die gießkanne
kann im augenblick keiner gebrauchen ich
wollte darauf hinaus dass wir im
niedriglohnbereich 20 prozent der
bevölkerung der vollzeitig geschöpf
vollzeitbeschäftigten 20 prozent im
bundesdurchschnitt nach einer studie der
stiftung von 2020 im niedriglohnbereich
beschäftigt sind wir haben in den
ostdeutschen ländern sind dabei bis zu
30% wir sind bei uns im ruhrgebiet in
vielen städten in vielen prekären
stadtteilen da unterwegs und die fallen
im augenblick komplett durchs raster
weil sie halt weder heizkostenzuschuss
kriegen weder sozialleistung kriegen
sondern ganz normal ihrer arbeit
nachgehen die machen ihre arbeit sind im
niedriglohnbereich im friseur bereich
50.000 menschen ungefähr im bereich
personen transportverkehr personen
taxifahrer fast 50.000 im
niedriglohnbereich und das sind die die
ich gerade in wien auch glaube ich
gemeinsam sehen und ansprechen müssen
das sind die die jetzt wirklich
abrutschen und da haben wir auch die die
angst den wohlstand zu verlieren und da
ist in den familien eine große
verunsicherung ich kann fürs ruhrgebiet
authentisch aus der lokale dazu und
sagen das ist wirklich ein thema aber
haben wir dann nicht regeln ein netz
also verschiedene beihilfen
wohngeld
aufstockungen also ist das nicht
sozusagen durch samen durch statistik
geregelt dass einfach geguckt steigen
die preise und die sozialleistungen
nicht angehoben werden dafür ist muss
also es nicht dafür muss man ja
sozialleistungen beziehen aber die
meisten das hat ja herr thür abgesagt
haben gar keine sozialleistungen sondern
verdienen ganz wenig und da wäre dann
die lösung dass man wirklich denken über
die steuer geht denn alle diese leute
geben ja steuererklärung ab und da kann
man ja sehen dass sie praktisch nichts
verdienen und dann könnte man so etwas
machen das haben die engländer schon so
eine art negative einkommenssteuer also
dass die leute die ganz wenig verdienen
kriegen müssen keine steuer zahlen
sondern kriegen doch was zurück vom
finanzamt nach dem motto jetzt ist ja
die energie lage für euch so schwierig
das kann man alles sehen anhand der
eingereichten steuererklärung jetzt
kriegt den zuschlag aber wenn das nicht
nur so ad hoc jetzt mit energie wir
haben ein grundlegendes problem wir
haben die höchste abgabenbelastung
steuern abgabeleistung in der oecd und
die last ist ja vor allem hoch als hätte
ich einen stollen der famab
sozialabgaben gerade bereits im unteren
einkommensbereich die sozialabgaben
brauchen ein ganz anderes system was im
prinzip den leuten viel mehr geld an
taschen lässt wenn man anfängt zu
arbeiten wir müssen arbeit belohnen ich
bin übrigens würden was negatives sagen
der niedriglohnsektor jahres ist
schlecht auf der anderen seite ist
besser als arbeitslosigkeit das auch
sagen da wollen leute in arbeit bringen
wir brauchen einen grundlegend umbau und
der umbau wäre auch möglich wenn der
staat eben mal sagen würde moment mal
wir haben so geringe staatsschulen es
hat nichts mit allen anderen dass es
auch mehr schuld machen dass uns die
bürger entlasten und lassen die richtige
steuerreform machen das traut sich
keiner was unbequem ist aber das muss
getan werden und nochmal ich klicke
jetzt für die entlastung der sogenannten
reichen um hier geht's wirklich auch um
diesen übergang der übergang von hartz
iv ihrer arbeit da und die teilweise
grenzbelastung von 80 prozent das lohnt
sich nicht dabei wie auch lieber zu
hause arbeiten das ist aber identisch
mit dem was er tut meint ich finde es
ein bisschen bizarr wie sehr und lange
wir jetzt darüber diskutieren dass
unsere komplette steuersystem ändern
müssen wende war verantwortlicher
sozusagen eigentlich jedenfalls aus
meiner sicht bei der notenbank sie
weiter und und bei den ölpreisen
vielleicht auch noch aber ich meine
jetzt unser ganzes steuersystem
umzubauen weil wir gerade probleme mit
den preisen haben finde ich jetzt so ein
bisschen gefährlich würde ich auch nicht
zu rasen blieben wir aber nochmal die
ezb die ezb ich finde sie die ezb auch
aber die ezb haben wir alleine gelassen
die frau merkel hat sich in der andrä ag
versteckt der gesagt hat wurde er über
takes weil sie sich nicht getraut offen
auszusprechen euro so nicht funktioniert
und grundlegend reformiert werden muss
das haben wir nicht gemacht und das aber
die politik wie ich finde eigentlich es
war ein verlogen zusagen immobilien
immer die böse ezb aber eigentlich sich
hinter ihm zu verstecken weil sie
brauchen reformen ihre form wohl nicht
gemacht ich habe ganz schnell eine ganz
praktische frage die hier bei facebook
kommt die kredite kredite verlieren doch
auch an wert oder hausbesitzer nicht
schulden profitieren ja sicher naja
die profitieren stimmt nicht die
profitieren nur unter der annahme dass
die immobilienpreise nicht alles klar
das will ich noch mal ich habe das thema
angesprochen wir haben drei
landtagswahlen die gruppe der
geringverdiener über die wir gesprochen
haben spielt in der wählerschaft ja eine
untergeordnete rolle wir wissen aus
allen umfragen dass die menschen die
wellen gehen überwiegend sagen mir geht
es wirtschaftlich gut in der tat haben
wir ja eine breite mitte die steuern und
abgaben zahlt aber trotzdem das gefühl
hat mir geht es ganz gut wir haben jetzt
relativ einvernehmlich darüber
gesprochen dass man sozial schwachen
helfen muss das in bestimmten
situationen auch entlastung wegen zur
abgaben sagen muss aber was ist mit der
großen mehrheit von der see her stellt
damit recht gesagt haben früher konnten
die sich ganz normal eine
eigentumswohnung kaufen und darauf
sparen familien die keine chance mehr
haben da wo sie ihren arbeitsplatz haben
auch nach der karte wohnung oder garten
haus zu finden
also was tut eine regierung die jetzt
gegenwind spürt im wahljahr angesichts
dieser mehrheit die am ende entscheidet
die politische zukunft was nicht der typ
der mark also die politik wird irgendwas
tun weil wir gehen ja mal davon aus wir
hoffen alle dass wir im märz/april dass
die korona pandemie das bedeutende thema
krone etwas zurückgeht und das dann halt
auch andere themen in den vordergrund
rücken und diese themen werden im
eigenen portemonnaie liegen das heißt
also sie habe gerade zurecht auch gesagt
das ist nicht nur die
niedriglohnempfänger betrifft aber
diejenigen die da in der russin die sich
bisher relativ sicher fühlten die auch
eine lebensplanung haben familienplanung
haben die eigentum anschaffen wollen die
merken jetzt dass es so weiter nicht
nicht funktioniert und wir haben in der
in der vorstehenden landtagswahlen ich
möchte nur kurz auf nrw zurückkommen das
bevölkerungsreichste land cdu fdp
regiert wir haben eine ganz spannende
konstellation nämlich dass das natürlich
die vielzitierte herz kann man die
sozialdemokratie ist die cdu regiert
wird wir haben ein spd-kanzler wir haben
eine ampelkoalition die gerne als
blaupause für nrw dienen möchte und in
der aktuellen situation wenn dieses
thema soziale gerechtigkeit so können
soziale komponente weiter von meiner
arbeit leben können wenn das thema
stärker wird wird sich die
bundesregierung massiv bewegen allein
schon mit blick auf die wahlen in
nordrhein-westfalen jetzt kann man sagen
nordrhein westfalen ist nicht der nabel
der welt aber ist politisch auch mit
blick auf rückenwind für die cdu
eventuell für einen märz und auch mit
blick auf bis hin zu bundesrat sitzen
sechs sitze immerhin und das macht das
regieren ja auch leichter hat die wahl
im mai eine ganz ganz wichtige
psychologische und politische bedeutung
also noch mal ganz konkret zu werden
also ich glaube dass man jetzt nicht nur
gucken muss auf die leute die vielleicht
ein eigenheim kaufen wollen sondern man
sollte jetzt auch mal sehen dass 50
prozent der deutschen und auch sehr
viele leute im ruhrgebiet sind mieter so
und ich glaube man als 50 prozent haben
ich habe 50 prozent haben eigentum und
50 prozent sind sind mieter und werden
jetzt nicht übermorgen ein haus kaufen
sondern und das heißt was man dann auch
bedenken muss wenn man da sozial tätig
wird ist wie schafft man es mietverträge
zu deckeln das für eine neue
mietverträge das ist auch ein
schwebendes thema nicht weil das ja
in der form wie es in berlin geplant
wurde vom bundesverfassungsgericht
gekippt ist und da werden sich die ganz
großen themen abspielen nicht beim
eigenheim aber ich würde gerne auch mal
eine sache sagen also man darf einfach
nicht vergessen weil dieser ganzen
inflations debatte es geht im kern um
ölpreise und wenn wir jetzt langfristig
nicht wollen dass die ölpreise weiter
steigen werden die leute in deutschland
zwei dinge machen müssen nämlich erstens
öl sparen man muss effizienter mit öl
umgehen beispielsweise ist es quatsch
dass ich so viele leute ein riesen suv
kaufen mit 25 tonnen dann ist ja klar
dass das auch teuer ist dieses auto zu
bewegen dass da wird man kleinere autos
brauchen und das andere ist natürlich da
arbeite die regierung daran ökoenergie
nicht wenn man feststellt zu teuer oder
gas ist ja die richtige idee zu sagen
okay dann setzen wir mal auf wind- und
solarenergie ebenfalls nicht so tun
können wir natürlich gegen dankbar bin
dankbar nein das ist das nächste thema
auf meinem zettel nach so
also ist einmal der der rat der
wirtschaftsweisen hat ausgerechnet dass
im vergangenen jahr ein drittel der
inflation auf co2 abgabe also nicht auf
ölpreise am weltmarkt sondern auf die
staatliche entscheidung zurückgeht co2
also energieverbrauch teurer zu machen
und nun sind wir gerade von 25 auf 30
euro pro tonne gestiegen sondern 50 euro
werden bis 2025 es gibt diskussionen ob
das nicht noch schneller geht
passt das zu der situation über die wir
gerade gesprochen haben dass die breite
mehrheit mit stromsteuer mit einer noch
immer nicht aufgelösten eeg abgabe mit
einem neuen aufschlag auf gas öl diesel
benzin im nächsten jahr
immer stärker zur kasse gebeten wird
also was wir jetzt erleben ist ja
eigentlich dass das ein bisschen
vorgezogen wird so kurzzeitig durch die
märkte also es wird quasi vorgezogen
dass wir erleben wie ist das eigentlich
wenn die energie so teuer wird und
schnell und plötzlich und ich finde
schon dass man argumentieren könnte zum
beispiel es gibt ja die idee diese
eeg-umlage ein bisschen früher dann
schon abzuschaffen eigentlich heute 2023
sein man könnte auch einfach schon
früher machen helfen ist jetzt
abgeschafft die andere hälfte sagt
lindner könnte aus seiner sicht auch
schon sofort ja also ich finde das
vernünftig wenn man wenn man das machen
würde ich glaube aber sozusagen unter
langfristigen gesichtspunkten
so will das land hin oder was wollen wir
erreichen ist es jetzt nicht sinnvoll in
abkehr zu machen von der idee co2 preise
zu erheben weil die einfache sozusagen
wenn man co2 vermindern will co2 ausstoß
vermindern will das beste instrument
sind man könnte natürlich überlegen ob
in zeiten wo preise so überschießend wie
derzeit ob man dann da ein bisschen
anpassung macht bei diesem politischen
preis aber jetzt deswegen das ziel ganz
aufzugeben das fände ich ganz falsch
und ich glaube auch er dass es gerade
diese lage
der aktuellen regierung ganz gut zupass
kommt also insbesondere den grünen die
haben doch jetzt noch mehr druck das
jetzt ganz schnell windenergie kommen
muss das ist jetzt ganz schnell noch
viel mehr erneuerbare energien ausgebaut
werden müssen weil wir ja sehen dass die
abhängigkeit von den fossilen energien
uns auch in andere probleme bringt
nämlich den preis probleme stellte ich
fragte nochmals also diese co2 abgabe
ist geplant worden mit ihren
steigerungen einer zeit ohne inflation
passt das noch
es ist politisch gewollt ich muss dazu
sagen ich einst korrigieren ich würde
widersprechen der these dass ein höherer
anteil erneuerbarer energien energie
billiger macht es gegen haben wir bis
jetzt gesehen das hat damit zu tun also
doppelstrukturen brauchen weil der wind
bläst nicht immer die sonne scheint
nicht immer hat man backup sondern auch
bezahlt werden das heißt vollkosten
betrachtet wird energie teurer und das
politisch gewollt und darüber hinaus ist
ja nicht nur so dass sie da mehr für die
heizung zahlen wer für das auto betanken
soll das zieht sich durch alles durch
bis hin zu düngemitteln nahrungsmittel
das hängt alles miteinander zusammen
billige und günstig energie ist
wohlstand das sind teurer energie ist
also knapper sie ist desto weniger
wohlstand hat man das ist aber die
tatsache dass ein politisch gewollt und
jetzt muss ich auch noch sagen was muss
ich das auch bei farmerama sagen jetzt
haben wir diesen anstieg der inflation
in den 16 daher hat man auch gemalt ja
das sind momentane schocks oder als der
ölpreis schock was es momentan und
notenbanken haben nicht reagiert damals
hat die us-notenbank nicht reagierte der
staat durch viele schulden hatte heute
geht die ezb nicht und damit haben da
eben das thema dass inflation dauerhaft
wird dann haben wir die energiepreise
die bewusst steigen sollen und wir haben
eine notenbank die nicht gegensteuern
kann und dann kommen die inflation kommt
ins laufen nicht morgen nicht schlecht
nicht dieses jahr aber im perspektivisch
dieses jahrzehnt und wir müssen ganz
klar sagen die politik muss ich ehrlich
machen wir wollen politisch das leben
teurer wird und energie wird nämlich
teurer und das heißt im klartext der
werden in zukunft weniger geld haben von
normalen konsum während wir gleichzeitig
übrigens auch noch staatlicherseits mehr
geld ausgeben sollen um solardächer und
ähnliches zu machen was auch geld kostet
das heißt wir haben eine andere
verschiebung in unserer ausgaben zu
lasten des konsums und was wir da haben
für uns ist ein massives sozial das
problem und die gelb westen in
frankreich haben uns vorgemacht was
irgendwann nächsten paar jahren in
deutschland auch kommen wird es war auch
eine reaktion auf ökosteuer freiherr man
hatte also was irgendwie klar sein muss
ist wir können den planeten nicht
aufheizen bis wir darauf nicht mehr
leben können also es ist sozusagen
zwingend auf co2 emission zu verzichten
weil wir sonst unser eigenes überleben
bedrohen so jetzt ist also die frage wie
macht man das sozial gerecht damit dass
mit dem geld westen hier in deutschland
nicht passiert und da wäre natürlich das
beste system gewesen dass man co2 preise
erhöht und das geld das man da einnimmt
als staat an die leute zurück gibt und
zwar in form eines sogenannten klima
geldes oder energie gilt ist das heißt
pro kopf würden alle das gleiche
bekommen was man vorher eingezahlt hat
und das hätte dann den effekt dass die
unteren schichten mehr bekommen würden
als sie selber bei co2 gezahlt haben
weil die ja wenig energie verbrauchen
weil sie wenig geld haben aber sie
würden sozusagen das gleiche pro kopf
zurück bekommen wie alle ja ist dass
kompliziertes modell habe ich nicht ganz
verstanden aber das heißt sie stimmen
grundsätzlich der beobachtung zu dass es
ein soziales problem ist wenn wir
zusätzlich zu den steigenden preisen
über etwas was ökologisch notwendig und
völlig richtig gedacht ist aber sag mal
zusätzlich genauer sagt wenn man das
wenn man das die co2 preise die der
stadt erhebt aber an die bürger zurück
gibt dann ist das ja für die kein keine
zusätzliche belastung sondern man
versteigerung war alles durch ist es
23 gedanken dazu zum einen muss von vier
der fairness halber sagen aus meiner
sicht dass die aktuelle bundesregierung
ja in vielen bereichen eine verkorkste
energiewende übernommen hat vieles
funktioniert halt nicht darf man mal so
als these würde ich mal rein geben in
die runde zweite bemerkung zu frau
herrmann die energieabgabe wahlkampf der
grünen wird diese legislatur nicht mehr
kommen ich glaube dass wir uns da einig
sind und dann fliegen was reden wir dann
ja und eine frau in gedanken noch zu
früh nienhaus ich weiß gar nicht ob das
im augenblick den grünen so in den kram
passt also man kann auf der einen seite
sagen die energiekosten steigen aber wir
brauchen einen gesellschaftlichen
konsens ich glaube dass er da ist also
das belegt wie viel zahlen belegen es
gibt einen gesellschaftlichen konsens
hin zu erneuerbaren energien hin zur
energiewende wenn aber die preise derart
weiter steigen wenn wir es weiter nicht
schaffen wie im vergangenen jahr
kaum
erneuerbare energien windkraft 480
windkraftanlagen in einem jahr das ist
nichts viele sind aus der eeg förderung
heraus gefallen also wir haben uns eher
verschlechtert das heißt der
gesellschaftliche konsens ist in gefahr
wenn dinge wie energie geld nicht kommen
und wenn die energiekosten steigen das
leben teurer wird ob gelb westen oder
andere soziale verwerfungen von
verwerfungen nicht sprechen also ein
sozialer konflikte die eine gesellschaft
auf rühren können im übrigen in eine
gesellschaft dieser zwei jahren
angeschlagen ist durch die
bewohner pandemie und ohnehin
verunsichert und zum teil sogar
radikalisiert ist das ist wirklich
sprengstoff was man richtung berlin ist
aber ich finde umso mehr dass genau
deshalb jetzt die notenbank gefragt ist
jetzt sozusagen was zu tun weil also
inflation wirkt ja auch so eine art und
weise die die so ein bisschen zufällig
ist also wie wie das vermögen umverteilt
wird durch inflation kann es nicht
irgendwie einfach von oben nach unten
und nach oben sondern es geht einfach
solche sozusagen querbeet manche leute
im glück manche hand hält und das wird
relativ schnell als sehr ungerecht
empfunden und deswegen wäre es jetzt
auch dringend zeit bevor auch sozusagen
diese grüne inflation wie es genannt
wird kommt dass die notenbank gezeigt
wir haben das im griff wir wollen das im
griff behalten und wird noch war ja da
kann ich mich nur wiederholen wenn die
zinsen steigen haben wir arbeitslose und
dann haben die leute kein lohn mir aber
ein bisschen zinsen aber keine so
hermann also da möchte ich auch was für
sagen weil das stimmt so nicht es kommt
darauf an wann handelt und es hat sich
in der vergangenheit schon erwiesen dass
je später gehandelt also je länger man
ist herauszuhören länger die notenbank
warten und hier später sie dann am ende
ganz harte maßnahmen ergreifen muss
desto härter wird die krise dies erzeugt
ich habe eine frage waren mal anfängt
das haben beide recht das problem ist
dass dieser sackgasse das ist ein
problem dass
eine rolle übernehmen
das wollte ich lebe ich wollte ich
wollte man die brücke bauen ich bin voll
bei ihnen natürlich muss die notenbank
bremsen die sechziger jahre dann ist es
nicht getan und damit inflation außer
kontrolle geraten das problem die ganze
sache ist mindestens noch
ist es die sackgasse wenn wir die zinsen
erhöhen dann kamen wir probleme ein
vermögensmärkten wir haben probleme mit
den schulden haben eine schwere
rezession dann sind die arbeitsplätze in
gefahr und das ist was das tempo an und
deshalb wird die ezb nicht dass du musst
von ihnen aus fordert und deshalb werden
wir deutlich die operation raten
perspektivisch nicht in dieses jahr
bekommen also ganz vereinfacht gesagt
und nicht um einen recht zu geben also
auf der einen seite wünscht man sich
dass die geldpolitik wieder in ein
normales wunsch das relative takt kommt
und auf der anderen seite dann können
wir uns höhere zinsen nur leisten wenn
die wirtschaft nicht abgewürgt dem haus
deshalb müssten wir politisch anders
darauf antworten ja ist das für die neue
bundesregierung plötzlich ein thema auf
der agenda das im wahlkampf noch niemand
gesehen hat dass bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen keine große
rolle gespielt hat und dass vielleicht
doch über wahlen entscheidet ich würde
mir wünschen dass es auf die agenda
kommt aber ich würde mir halt wünschen
dass es grundsätzlich auf die agenda
kommt nicht nur mit der sorge ich habe
jetzt die wahl in nrw und dann muss ich
möglichst vorher sechs verteilen sondern
man muss grundlegende dran denken und da
habe ich meine zweifel
welche rolle spielen würde eine wichtige
rolle spielen eindeutig also gerade
während nrw gewinnen will muss im
ruhrgebiet stark abschneiden und gut
sehr gut abschneiden als alte regel in
nrw und deswegen spielt die soziale
karte wird gespielt auch von der
bundesregierung bedanke mich vor allem
ich glaube es ist ein wald von
ökonomischer debatten aber ich glaube
dass wir am sonntag schneisen geschlagen
und auf ein paar wichtige punkte drauf
geschaut bedanken nicht herzlich wenn
sie in der ard dabei sind dann in europa
magazin mit dem bericht aus brüssel die
jetzt welche rolle die eu bei globalen
konflikten spielt bleiben sie aber auch
gerne dabei bei phoenix im fernsehen im
radio bei wdr 5 presseclub nachgefragt
bisher in danke tschüss und lassen sie
diskutieren
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück preis der klub
nachgefragt im fernsehen bei phoenix im
radio bei bdr 5 sie sind dran und
zunächst mal würde ich die
damen im publikum bitten etwas aktiver
zum telefon zu greifen im moment
schreien eher das alte vorurteil zu
bestätigen dass ökonomie an ein
männliches thema ist christoph werner in
hildesheim trotzdem herzlich willkommen
in der sendung stellen dass sie dabei
sind
werner und ich grüße an schönen
sonntagmorgen noch sie haben das
direkt an die frau heran
die ja sich so für die niedrigzins
politik der ezb ein ich arbeite jetzt
seit 48 jahren im sozialen bereich und
das sind die löhne ja nicht so hoch wie
jeder andere sich statt im industrie-
gewerbe- vorstellt ich habe immer was
für meine rente zurückgelegt aber
seitdem die ezb das alles runter gesetzt
obwohl ich gespielt habe ist mein spaß
ist so hoch gesunken dass nur noch die
tränen in die augen getroffen um eine
rente sieht ab nächstes jahr 48 jahren
ganz gelinde ausgedrückt sehr sehr
dürftig aus ich würde viel lieber
deutlicher ausdrücken dass mancher
werden öffentlich rechtlichen gehören
natürlich nicht meine frage ist was
wollen sie den heutigen spaß sagen ja
also sie haben natürlich völlig recht
dass es sehr schwierig ist mit den
ersparnissen wenn die zinsen so niedrig
sind aber es stellen sie sich jetzt mal
vor was passieren würde wenn man die
zinsen hoch setzt nicht dann habe ich ja
schon erklärt würde das wahrscheinlich
die wirtschaft schwer belasten es gelbe
arbeitslosigkeit jetzt wissen sie aber
auch dass die renten sprich auch ihre
rente wird bezahlt von den leuten die
arbeiten wenn jetzt also die
arbeitslosigkeit steigt ist das nächste
ergebnis dass es ein loch in der
rentenkasse gibt und dann werden auch
die wenn es erstmal arbeitslosigkeit
gibt steigen auch die löhne nicht mehr
jetzt wissen sie aber dass auch die
renten und ihre erhöhungen davon
abhängen ob die löhne steigen dh das
ergebnis würde sein wenn die ezb die
zinsen erhöht dass ihre rente nicht mehr
steigt und tatsächlich sogar in gefahr
ist so liter wärme
werne das war jetzt die erklärung von
freiherr man
überhaupt
kartenspieler komplettiert ja ich glaube
also nicht mal sagen gehabt was was ihre
frage deutlich macht ist dass sie in der
tat zu den menschen gehören die für eine
politische entwicklung bezahlen das ist
sehr bitter aber muslera bezahlbar herr
werner ist die zahl der im prinzip die
unteren einkommen vermögens gruppen
bezahlen halt dann eine politik die auch
ihnen jetzt nutzt aber auch andere
überproportional nutzen das zeigt das
dilemma eben und das ist dieses dieser
sprengsatz der sich da einer
gesellschaft bilden werner ich bin ihnen
dankbar dass wir das so bitter sie
dürfen
für die rente zurückgelegt
herr werner alles gute große nach
hildesheim wir springen an den
niederrhein nach dinslaken zu uwe
neuhaus oder ist das aus ihrer sicht
nach ruhrgebiet
es wird nicht sagen ja sie sind dran
danke dass sie dabei sind
wenn die inflation so hoch bleibt die
tat am ende auch arbeitsplätze kosten
also die ist argument ist bruder meine
frage ist kann die cd nicht dass
leistungen erhöhen weil damit fiele eine
ente gepimpte staaten dann wirklich
bankrott wären ja in spanien 2 verlieren
werden wir jahren im monat getroffen der
ezb und das führt zu inflation und ein
licht erhöhung der finden
wichtigen funktionen zu bleiben gemäss
hinaus ja sie haben insofern recht als
dass
es am ende so ist wenn die zinsen erhöht
werden das wird wahrscheinlich erst
passieren nachdem die ezb ihre
anleihenkaufprogramme zurück fährt sie
kauft ja immer noch einen sehr großen
maße staatsanleihen und senkt damit die
zinsen die die europäischen staaten
zahlen müssen wenn sie sich verschulden
und wenn die ezb sondern zuerst dieser
staatsanleihen kaufprogramme beendet was
bis jetzt die ezb präsident in sagt und
auch die meisten mitglieder im rat so
befürworten dann wird das dazu führen
dass die zinsen für die staaten da
ansteigen und dass sie für die staaten
wieder sehr viel teurer wird womöglich
für manche sich zu verschulden und das
ist natürlich auch eine gefahr vor der
die ezb steht und auch was wo sie
natürlich gucken muss dass sie nicht
wenn sie das macht eine neue krise
wieder auslöst also ich glaube es ist
jetzt im moment gar nicht so die große
gefahr aktuell aber natürlich ist das
eine sorge die immer eine rolle spielt
weil sie eben diese reihenfolge
festgelegt da zinsen erst erhöhen wenn
man die staatsanleihenkäufe beendet hat
ich glaube dankeschön ich glaube wir
hatten das ja eingangs der sendung dass
das ein bisschen wie eine droge ist das
angesagt jetzt gesagt das ist das letzte
mal billiger wird genau herr neuhaus
danke
ich sehe im netz eine frage von von
rainer k in unserem gästebuch nicht nur
die inflation sondern auch ferrari
entgelte fressen unsere guthaben auf das
sind die sogenannten negativzinsen warum
sorgt die bundesregierung nicht für
gesetzlich festgelegte freibeträge
gibt es die diskussion also die
inflation ich weiß nicht ob sie sich tot
aber ist natürlich auch noch das ist
auch herumdoktern an symptomen
das ist rum doppler so könnte man machen
ich meine warum machen sie sind nicht
mal warum machen die banken die wahlen
gelten weil ihre marge unter druck
gekommen sind ich meine warum haben die
bankaktien sich den letzten wochen
erhöht weil er etwas hoffnung etwas soft
und etwas höhere zinsen war lange keine
zinsen haben aber wir warten das problem
das heißt das kann man rum doch dann
aber eigentlich da appell wäre das
grundlegende problem zu lösen nämlich
die eurozone zu sanieren wir gehen nach
freudenstadt hans-peter schwer
willkommen in der sendung
wie kann es sein dass über unsere
wertvollsten ressourcen wie erdöl und
erdgas und getreide an der börse gezockt
wird das kann doch nicht sein
eine antwort das wäre super van gaal an
den ok dann schaue ich mal wäre wahrlich
wurde vorher zustimmen und ich würde
sagen ich gehe mutig verraten ich würde
mal sagen das klingt ein bisschen sehr
negativ ich glaube die den börsen eine
funktion mit preissignale dafür zu
sorgen dass je mehr produziert wird
weniger produziert wird und so weiter
und wenn sie an den weizen frei zum
beispiel denken dass für die
amerikanischen pharma ist es sehr
wichtig dass sie die möglichkeit haben
quasi ihre das schon zu verkaufen bevor
sie sie geerntet haben es gibt also
schon nutzen in den finanzmärkten man
muss ich aufpassen dass ich übertrieben
würde aber man kann es nicht generell
sagen wer wird gezockt und das
grundlegende problem ist wir einfach
haben ist wir fördern uns zurzeit zu
wenig öl für die weltweite nachfrage und
das ist einfach eine marktentwicklung
und ich glaube in der tat da muss man
darüber nachdenken die kann man das
verstetigen und da machen wir nehmen auf
passes mit der klimaschutzpolitik
weltweit nicht übertreibt damit die
nicht ausreichend investiert wird noch
eine förderung weil auch noch auf die
welt über das wunder einer weile so
bleiben herr schwer danke für den
gedankenanstoß den wir gut
nachvollziehen können groß nachfordern
stadt und petra osinski in hamburg hat
uns angerufen tag frau sitzkissen dran
durchschlagen
die lebenshaltungskosten
denn ich beobachte schon seit zwei
jahren das waren des täglichen bedarf
nicht um 5 prozent sondern um 10 oder 25
prozent ansteigen und das wird meines
erachtens auch so bleiben selbst wenn
der erdölpreis wieder sinken sollte
danke danke frau sehr
vielen dank für ihre frage also wenn man
jetzt die statistik an guckt aber das
sind die dann in ihre richtung war es so
dass die lebensmittelpreise im letzten
jahr um sechs prozent gestiegen sind ist
ja auch eine menge und das liegt daran
dass die produktion von lebensmitteln
unglaublich energieintensiv ist das hat
herr stelter auch schon mal ganz kurz
erwähnt in der sendung also zum beispiel
düngemittel werden durch energie
synthetisiert also zum beispiel wird ja
ganz wesentlich stickstoff aus der luft
gesorgt um daraus düngemittel zu machen
das ist alles wahnsinnig energieintensiv
in dem moment wo der ölpreis hoch geht
geht eben auch automatisch das ist
erstaunlich der lebensmittelpreise wie
glaubwürdig ist denn die statistik also
ich kenne das auch das weiße sehe wo ich
rechne und lenke durch sind aber eher 20
oder 30 prozent
ich sehe natürlich nicht die preise die
gleich bleiben also mein
kartoffelhändler hat mir gestern
versichert er habe sogar im sommer die
preise gesenkt und ewig nicht erhöht
aber aber wie belastbar ist das was wir
inflationsraten ich glaube es ziemlich
belastbar also ich habe mir letztens für
einen artikel tatsächlich noch mal
angeguckt wie wird sie eigentlich ganz
genau berechnet wie wir sie ganz genau
erhoben und da habe ich mit leuten
telefoniert unter anderem die
tatsächlich
tagtäglich oder ein paar tage die woche
in verschiedenen läden gehen und da
genau die preise ab schreiben die haben
eine vorgabe von den statistischen
landesämtern da gehen sie dahin
schreiben genau aufpreis so so so und
ich habe mit einem hamburger telefoniert
er das machte und der hat gesagt er
beobachtet im letzten halben jahr
tatsächlich durch die bank egal was
alles wird teurer also nur um das man zu
sagen es ist nämlich nicht nur die
energie und es sind nicht nur die
lebensmittel es wird alles mögliche
teuer und es ist auch nicht nur so dass
wir sagen können wegen irgendwelchen
ölpreisschocks sind wir jetzt in dieser
situation oder wegen putin sondern es
gibt einen gesamttrend danke wir gehen
weiter nach sangerhausen in
sachsen-anhalt zu irgend fuchs kommen
tag konnte ich habe eine frage an herrn
stelter wir haben eine wunderbare
bemerkung gemacht aus meiner sicht in
dem sie auf die gelb westen in
frankreich verwiesen und meine frage
geht an sie wie kann man denn verhindern
dass die derzeitige inflation sich
verstetigt und zu derart sozialen
verwerfungen führt dass wir das nicht
mehr beherrschen den stefan zweig hat ja
im verweis auf die weimarer republik
wenn ich das in erinnerung rufen dort
eine restlichen gesetz gesetz gesagt
nichts hat die deutsche bevölkerung die
so sehr mit hat erfüllt wie eine
inflation ich möchte das nicht
fortsetzen sie wissen was ich meine
das sind hat er die lieder auf die
bevölkerung zucker also ich weiß was sie
meinen ich möchte noch einst kanzler
betonen die zwanzigerjahre
prognostiziere ich nicht ich glaube auch
keiner hier im raum also inflationsraten
wie in der weimarer republik wird nicht
am horizont aber es könnte er sein wie
den 70er 80er jahren strukturell höheren
inflationsrate ich glaube das ist das
szenario und die wichtige frage auf die
wichtige frage ist wir müssen zum einen
die niedrigeren einkommensgruppen
entlasten das müsste eigentlich
konsequenterweise mindestlohn und erhöhe
mit den fusions rather müsste die
sozialabgaben grenze mit der
inflationsrate erhöhen das müsste sagen
quasi mobil sein das zweite machen
müssen wir müssen dringend da bin ich
anderer auffassung als vorher müssten
dringend mehr tun um dem uns allen zu
helfen vermögen zu sichern indem das
geld richtig anlegen also eine höhere
quote weil er andere ländern viel
höheren quoten andere hebel auch über
über internationale anlage wie gedenken
sie an norwegen die staatsfonds haben
warum können wir nicht weil das
ähnliches mara für die bürger vom staat
finanziert das ein bisschen ganz kreativ
darüber nachdenken wie wir als land
unser geld anlegen von hintergrund
strukturelle höherer inflationsraten
weil die kommen so sicher wie es an
einer kirche eben aufgrund dieser
sackgasse da wir sind gepaart mit dem
klima umbau und einigen anderen faktoren
die eine rolle spielen bei notenbank
eben nicht reagieren wird so sehr ich
war weiß ronny ausbilden und bei
wünschen würde sie können das tun sie
wollte es nicht tun
fuchs
ich danke zunächst ja ja ich
natürlich unbefriedigend
die inflation verselbstständigt sich
irgendwie und der größte nutznießer ist
ja der staat
seine schulden sind die nutznießer ganz
klar mehr oder weniger
geld vernichtet herr fuchs vielen
herzlichen dank
viele gute anstöße jetzt in dieser
viertelstunde ich gehe mal nach
dudweiler vermutet vom namen her dass es
eher im südlichen teil deutschlands
liegt aber das wird axel mal ganz genau
wissen guten tag
hier aktuell magath weil er liegt im
nördlichen saarland im kreistag
und dann richtig
ist wie ein rentner haushalt und ein
haushalt und niedrigverdienern wie hoch
die preisspirale beziehungsweise die
inflation frage in den letzten monaten
für diese gering verdienende haushalte
wie kann sie wenn ihr das bewusstsein
soll davon sprechen dass die inflation
ausschließlich aus den energiepreisen
resultiert zweite frage machen die runde
warum wird dann nicht das hauptproblem
diskutiert hier die existenz des euros
viele probleme hat muss er gar nicht
wenn wir den euro nicht retten man muss
dann eben auch mal den mut haben den
euro in frage zu stellen und die frage
aufzustellen wo wird denn deutschland
heute stehen mit welcher inflationsrate
wenn man den euro nicht hatte wenn wir
also
unsere währung selbst bestimmen könnten
und die dritte frage zu sagen die
argumentation davon hamann so stimmt
mit
inflationsrate bezüglich stabilität des
arbeitsmarktes braucht es wenn dann die
schweiz unterwegs die hat stabile
inflation gerade ihr habt ein stabiles
niveau und wir haben keine hohen
arbeitslosenzahl yamaga ich danke ihnen
herzlich die erste frage haben wir im
prinzip beantwortet das haben wir
relativiert das glaube ich ist in ihrem
sinne für die dritte bleibt die zeit
nicht aber die zweite finde ich spannend
ich schlag vor da machen da eine antwort
versucht also jedenfalls
was war die zweite frage nach dem euro
und inflation wir ohne den euro hätten
das hätte wahrscheinlich
weniger inflation weil aber das ist
nicht unbedingt eine gute nachricht wenn
sie es nicht vorstellen wir hätten den
euro nicht sondern die d-mark dann wird
weltweit alle leute in der d mark
investieren weil wir so sagen wir werden
wie die schweiz weil wir also gehabt
weil wir als sicherer hafen gelten und
die kurse dass der d-mark würden extrem
nach oben schießen und das würde unsere
exportindustrie wahnsinnig stark
belasten das wäre eigentlich keine gute
idee sagt herr stelter wieso das macht
die schweiz doch auch aber die schweiz
hat zwei andere bedingungen das eine ist
sie ist eine steueroase jetzt kann aber
nicht
die schweizer export wird hermann
riesiger bringen der euro ist die
rettung der deutschen exportindustrie
und wir sollten ihn nicht aufgeben ja
herr magath so könne der eine eigene
sendung machen nachrichten
danke gruß ins saarland bedanke mich
sehr herzlich bei der runde auch jetzt
für das letzte aus klärung vieler vieler
offener fragen und viele kluge gedanken
genießen sie den sonntagswetter als
wunderbar gehen sie raus an die frische
luft sonne unsere sonne zu hosen achten
im nächsten sie das frühjahr einen
schönen sonntag aus köln
[Musik]